ron desantis down in florida has been
i think the leader as far as governors
go on this issue and it's why the left
is going after him did you see this
yesterday i i hope you saw this i know
that very few people who listen to this
show watch 60 minutes
because very few people generally watch
60 minutes anymore
and hopefully it'll be fewer and fewer
moving into the future
60 minutes total network news
hit piece on ron desantis
60 minutes played an exchange between
one of their reporters and ron desantis
on an issue not really only tangentially
related to the vaccines
it's about an allegation of corruption
and whether
a supermarket chain donated some money
to ron desantis in florida and so
desantis gave them a special contract
on the vaccine total bs it's completely
bogus which we'll get to in a minute
but just listen to the exchange as 60
minutes presents it
we wanted to ask governor desantis about
the deal but he declined our request for
an interview
we caught up with them south of orlando
publix as you know donated a hundred
thousand dollars to your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccinations
so first of all that what you're saying
is right how is that not paid that's a
fake narrative
i met with the county mayor i met with
the administrator i met with all the
folks at palm beach county and i said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publix and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
but melissa mckinlay the county
commissioner in the glades told us
the governor never met with her about
the public's deal
the criticism is that it's paid a place
it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
okay wow if you were to listen to that
exchange i think you would say
gosh maybe he there is some corruption
here because he didn't lay it out in a
way that's irrefutable he didn't take
her through
anything he just made this claim that he
met with some mayors and county people
and then some other county person said
they didn't and then
and there were some really good shots of
the reporter smirking at
desantis and saying this is corruption
okay right that's interesting
thankfully we have the full
footage of that exchange which
went nothing like what that clip would
suggest
i'm not even going to play the whole
exchange just take a listen to the first
part of the exchange and compare it to
what 60 minutes aired
so first of all that what you're saying
is wrong that's that that's a fake
narrative
so first of all when we did the the
first pharmacies that had it were cvs
and walgreens
and they had a long-term care mission so
they were going to the long-term care
facilities
they got vaccine in the middle of
december they started going to the
long-term care facilities
the third week of december to do ltc's
so that was their mission
that was very important and we trusted
them to do that
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other retail
pharmacies publix walmart obviously cbs
and walgreens had to finish that mission
and we said we're gonna we're gonna use
you as soon as you're done with that for
the publix
they were the first one to raise their
hand say they were ready to go and you
know what we did it on a trial basis
i had three counties i actually showed
up that weekend
and talked to seniors across four
different publics
this goes on for like a minute and a
half in addition to what we've already
heard
where he's laying out step by step
exactly the plan saying no we didn't
give this exclusive contract to publix
we started at cvs we start then went to
walgreens then we opened it up
publix was the first one that could do
it we did polls of the senior citizens
we found out most senior citizens live
within a mile of publix it's proven very
popular it's why we're leading the
country and these goes on and on and on
and on
the reporter has nothing and then she
keeps coming back and saying well but
this is bad and he says okay well i've
disabused you of this narrative
i guess you're not paying attention but
i've just laid
it out for you absolutely people should
lose their jobs over what just happened
in 60 minutes
whatever producer or reporter quote
unquote put that thing together
should be fired and should never work in
reporting again if they want to become
leftist commentators
on msnbc that would be more honest more
understandable
but what they just what they just did on
60 minutes is
lie they committed fraud on 60 minutes
why are they doing this to desantis
they're doing it to him
because they're afraid of him because
they think that he would be a formidable
presidential candidate in 2024 it's the
same reason they're going after cruz
for cancun i the whole time i maybe i
mentioned this at the time when when
the cruise in cancun story was the
biggest story in the world
why why was everybody going after cruz
all the time because the left felt that
he would be a formidable candidate in
2024
they're doing it to desantis because he
also would be a formidable candidate
in 2024 they only go after people that
they're afraid of you're not going to
see 60-minute hit pieces
on john kasich frankly if if the left is
not going after a republican politician
i am skeptical of that politician i'm
probably not going to support that
politician
and i think you know i i don't
anticipate
that there's going to be some big expose
on mitt romney let's put it that way
okay desantis right now
is one of the big targets there are two
or three big targets on the right
he's one of them and he's stating with
clarity this is not just about
government mandates on the vaccine this
extends to
private businesses as well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you